My husband was on his way out to grab a burger
when I realised that we had all the ingredients at home to make one,
so that's exactly what I did.
I got started with my dough for my burger buns,
combined some flour,
water, yeast,
egg and some butter and let that go until it all came together.
Once it was soft and smooth,
I placed it in a different bowl to rise for about two hours.
Once it had doubled in size,
I turned it out and cut it up in eight pieces
and form those into little balls,
making sure that they were all the same size.
I repeated that with all of my pieces of dough
and place them on my baking sheet.
I then lightly press them down to flatten them out a little
before covering them with a towel
and letting them rise for another hour.
Once they were puffy,
I brush them with some melted butter
and also beat up an egg with some water to brush on top of that,
and then I opted to sprinkle my buns with some sesame seeds,
pop those in the oven for about 15 minutes
and got started on making a quick pickle.
Sliced up some cucumbers and made my brine
before adding some smashed garlic and peppercorn to that.
I set that aside and got started on my patties,
which was just some ground beef
and I smashed it really thin before seasoning it with Some salt,
pepper, and some seasoning. Salt.
This point my buns were done,
so I let them cool and moved on to slicing all of my toppings,
which were some tomatoes,
red onions, some lettuce,
and I laid them out so that would be easier to assemble.
The last step was frying my patties.
So I got my pan really hot and seared it on both sides
before adding some white cheddar cheese on top.
And once that was melted,
I assembled his burger with the patties,
some tomato, the lettuce on top.
He doesn't like sauce on his burger,
so I put some homemade ketchup on the side.
He always needs a sprinkle of flaky sea salt on that.